FOR THIRTY JANUARY TWENTY THIRD
IS HEREBY CALLED ORDER. ADVICE
ON AUDIO VIDEO RECORDING TODAY
PROCEEDINGS MADE HAS ALSO BEEN
TELEVISED. AMERICA CENTER
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY
HERE KINDA. CORREO HERE FLORA.
GRAYSON KAMLAGER MAY. AFTER
QUIRK SILVA HERE FROM MOST HERE
RIVAS WHAT HERE ONE WE HAVE A
AND WE HAVE A CAN AND FOR THE
MOST ACOSTA AGENDA SO DECEMBER
OVER SUGAR ARE GRAYSON ST
MYSTERON HAVE SECTOR PLEASE
CALL ROLL CALLING ALL COOLEY
AYE CUNNINGHAM KIND I. KERR.
CARILLO AYE FLORA FLORA HI.
GRACE AYE AYE KAMLAGER MAIN
SHOW I MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS QUIRK
SILVA. HI QUIRK SILVA IRA.
RAMOS I READ. I RECONCILING
FINE BY SIDE.
FIFTY FOUR.
KAMLAGER SEVEN OKAY MISTER
MATHIS HERE I AM CONSENT YES AT
HIS SIDE THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER THANK YOU VERY MUCH.